the removal of the superintendent no
doubt has a lot of families reacting
christian casadas continues our team
coverage with what parents are upset
about which is also sparking a lot of
dialogue online christian that's right
denise we spoke to several families
today about last night's decision and
many tell us they only want what's best
for their children the rant also flowing
online and parents aren't holding back
big big mistake get rid of the board
especially ford you are not for our kids
is what one family wrote on facebook
roger also posting there is a reason
that our students do so poorly and are
at the bottom of the educational ladder
and trust me it's not the teachers the
ccsd is incompetent lacks any leadership
and is focused only on their own
self-serving interests a heated outcome
both last night and online as a ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrah is
removed many families claiming jarrah
was out of touch with teachers and
families especially when the pandemic
hit
now they want change i think it's going
to be for the better i think somebody
needs to get in there that really cares
about the kids that have a heart for the
kids that's going to focus on the kids
so the kids get the education that they
need some parents told us although they
don't interact on a daily base with the
superintendent they felt jarrah was out
of touch with the school teachers and
ultimately the needs of the students
they hope the next leader will focus and
rebuild the district from the ground up
a lot of emotions both off and online
about this issue now parents say
jarrah's position comes with a heavy
salary and that title should be given to
someone that will do what's best for
students and not politics christian casa
is live local now